hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others
so
uh please
do ask questions about things that
you've heard about wonder what they are
i'll see if i know
uh anything about
science different areas of science
technology mathematics
things like that i'm happy to address a
whole variety of different kinds of
questions assuming that i think i know
the answers to them
um
i noticed we have quite a few left over
from previous times let me try and um
uh take a look at a few of these
um
oh here's an interesting one okay from
carrot
they say since photons do not experience
the passing of time does that mean that
all their physical properties such as
wavelength are fixed through their
lifespan okay that's kind of an
interesting
question so
the passage of time
is something that
is
in a sense dependent on
the well in relativity theory dependent
on reference frame or effectively
dependent on things like how fast you're
moving through space
so the main result is
that if you have two clocks for example
one of them you think of as being at
rest you're
sitting there with it so to speak
another clock is in a spacecraft that's
zooming past
at a large fraction of the speed of
light
then the clock that zooming past
will be running less quickly than the
clock that's sitting at rest relative to
you
and there's a way to understand this in
our models of physics finally there's
actually a way to sort of i think
intuitively understand what's happening
in a sense
what what happens okay so the universe
in our theories of physics
is made of this whole sort of giant
network
of points
of space
and the details of how that network is
connected are what determine what give
you things like particles like electrons
and things like that those are all just
features of the details of the structure
of space
so
if you want to move through space what
that means is the thing that represents
you
has to essentially recreate itself in a
different place in this giant network so
it's like something like a vortex
in in a fluid like water you know that's
it's spinning around a little vortex and
that vortex can move around in the water
but the actual molecules that are
involved in the vortex will be changing
as the vortex moves from one place to
another but the structure of the vortex
will stay the same and so we think it is
in the way that things like us
might move through space or like the
clock that we're looking at might move
through space
so in effect moving through space motion
takes essentially computational effort
things are happening the structure of
space is getting recreated rewritten to
represent the fact that this thing that
represents the clock or you or whatever
else
is taking up a different position in
space
so there's in a sense computational
processing going on to rewrite the
structure of space to allow motion
so
when
time
goes forward and the clock is ticking
because it's got some pendulum going
back and forth or it's got some crystal
that's oscillating whatever it is that
makes the clock tick
that that process of the clock ticking
is something which also takes
computational effort
so what happens is you've got these two
things that take computational effort
moving forward in time
and
moving yourself to a different place in
space that is
a motion to one play from one place to
another and so what happens in
relativistic time dilation as it's
called is that you're essentially
trading off those two things you're
saying i'm moving a lot so i'm using up
my kind of computation budget doing that
motion and i don't have as much
computation budget left over to actually
evolve through time so that's kind of
why in our models
the
time dilation happens that you're using
up your computational effort moving
through space so time runs more slowly
for you
that's what happens with time dilation
so the limiting case of time dilation is
what happens when you're moving at the
speed of light when you're moving at the
speed of light
time simply doesn't pass
because
there's infinite time dilation you're
kind of using all of your effort to just
move
and there's no no computational effort
left over to actually evolve in time and
so for photons which travel at the speed
of light that's what's happening they
are sort of using all of their sort of
computation power
to to do the motion at the speed of
light and none of it to change their own
character or to change anything about
them so that means that a photon that's
just sort of moving freely not running
into anything
no time is passing for that photon so
for example
at the beginning of the universe
the universe at very early moments was
very hot and was kind of like a a
fireball of of something where you
couldn't see through the fireball but
about a hundred thousand years after the
beginning of the universe it cooled down
to the point where that sort of fireball
uh the the um the the plasma kind of um
turned into ordinary hydrogen gas and
the thing became transparent and any
photon that was emitted from that
fireball when it became transparent at
the moment when it became transparent
that photon is just going to keep going
keep going keep going and in fact we can
pick up those photons that's what the
cosmic microwave background is it's
photons that started their journey
uh at the hundred thousand years or
whatever after the beginning of the
universe
and uh they've survived all that time
until the moment when they hit our radio
detector or whatever and we say yes
there was a photon there but for all
that whatever it is 14 billion years
they've just been traveling freely and
if you were that photon so to speak then
no time would have passed it's as if you
were born at the beginning of the
universe
and then nothing no time passed and then
you crash into some
some detector that those pesky humans
put up to to catch you so to speak
so so in a sense um no time passes there
now
what happens is a photon has certain
characteristics it is going in a
particular direction has a particular
momentum it has a particular energy the
energy determines its wavelength its
frequency etc
those things are completely unchanged if
the photon is just propagating freely
through space
the only way those things change is by
the photon scattering from something
like for example let's say it uh goes uh
it goes near an atom and it's it's kind
of made to uh sort of change its
momentum direction or it runs into that
detector and it's just completely
absorbed those are things that change
sort of the the direction the the the
characteristics of a photon but
otherwise a photon just goes on its
merry way at the speed of light no time
is passing and
it's uh
that's how it works and its
characteristics can't change now small
footnote that's a little bit tricky
when the photon was emitted
from
um
the uh the early universe it was uh a
photon that had a whole bunch of energy
it was it was kind of a photon uh let's
see probably about um
uh
well it was the equivalent of a visible
light photon um like the kind of photon
that would come from the surface of the
sun
but by the time we receive it it has
been doppler shifted to become a
microwave photon that has only a very a
much lower energy
and the reason that happens
really has nothing to do with the photon
itself
it's because
in effect the
the expansion of the universe makes the
thing that's emitting it recede from us
at something close to the speed of light
okay what do i mean by all of this
so you might have noticed if you hear
some you know some vehicle with a siren
going past you it'll go you know
you'll always hear as the thing
approaches you it'll seem like it's
higher frequency it'll be
and then as it goes past yours
goes to lower frequencies
um the reason that's happening it's a
phenomenon called doppler shift and the
reason that's happening is the sound
waves that are coming to you they're a
succession of waves and let's say
uh that the at the source
on of the siren let's say it was
producing waves ten thousand times a
second so it's producing crests of sound
waves ten thousand times a second that's
off ten thousand times a second
but the point is when that thing is
moving towards you
then there's both the rate at which it's
producing sound waves but then more of
those sound waves are getting to you
because of the motion of that thing
they're sort of piling up more of those
waves and so the frequency will be
higher as it goes away from you that
it's kind of like it's producing waves
at that frequency but
that they will not pile up they will
elongate away from you because of the
motion of the of the actual source of
sound and so it will be lower frequency
and that's what's happening in the case
of photons that it isn't that anything
was changed about the photon it's just
that the source of the photon was
effectively receding from you because of
the expansion in the universe in that
case um and so the effective energy
frequency of the photon is lower
so that's kind of the the answer that
it's kind of an interesting thing to
imagine if you imagine sort of a a whole
civilization that existed with with
photons and where the only way the
photons interact is that kind of two
photons meet on a grain of dust
somewhere or or a hydrogen atom
somewhere in the universe
and there's a sort of a big network of
just photons interacting and and they
you know they might propagate for a
billion years and then uh then interact
and then propagate for another billion
years
and to us it's like a billion years past
but to the photons it's no time at all
passed between the time when they lost
between the different interactions that
they have so it's kind of an interesting
sort of science fictiony thing to
imagine what would it be like if you've
experienced the history of the universe
as a photon so to speak
perhaps as a photon that scattered just
a few times since the beginning of the
universe what would that what would that
seem like to you
that kind of brings us to another
question that was asked here from uh
bobby
asking do you think it's worth investing
in attempting cryonic suspension as a
way to continue living
and that's that's strangely related to
what i was talking about with photons so
what is cryonics
so
the basic issue is
when
you have a an organism a biological
organism like a human
and the human
dies it's like it's all over it's an
irreversible thing never coming back but
what if you could freeze the human what
if you could put it in you know put it
in the freezer so to speak
and
then
uh
and then just reanimate it at some point
in the future
so people have been trying to do that
for a long time with with humans it
turns out that there are at least
amphibians which can get kind of frozen
in the ice all winter
and they kind of uh they they're pretty
much
not you know they're pretty much their
metabolism has stopped and then come
throwing time in the uh um they they
sort of happily come back to life and
they're many organisms that many even
mammals that hibernate although they
don't go to the state of being
absolutely sort of frozen with nothing
happening they just go to lower heart
rate and so on and and lower energy
consumption
but the question is could you
take
a
human for example and actually just
completely freeze them so that they're
in you know it's a temperature of liquid
nitrogen or something and absolutely
nothing is happening no chemical
processes are going on nothing is
decomposing
no bacteria attacking things just
absolutely frozen
and leave it that way for a hundred
years 200 years whatever and then say
okay let's throw it out again and uh
come back to life so to speak and be uh
you know happily continue
okay there is one key problem
which has
really prevented this from working which
is the following thing that seems like
it shouldn't be relevant but it is which
is water expands when it freezes and
since we are predominantly made of water
what happens is the water in our cells
if you try and take a human for example
and freeze them the water in our cells
will expand and it'll basically destroy
the cells
in that expansion process and you see
the same kind of thing if you take
oh i don't know raspberries or something
and you and you freeze them even you put
them in liquid nitrogen to freeze them
and you do it quite quickly um it will
tend to be the case that the the uh the
water in them will freeze and expand and
break down the cell walls and you'll get
a very mushy raspberry when you when you
re-animate it so to speak when you heat
it up again and so that's been the key
problem is how do you prevent
uh kind of the as you freeze
a a biological organism like us how do
you prevent the water in it from
expanding and basically destroying the
the structure of the organism
so there are various ideas for this
that involve various kinds of
anti-freeze substances and glycol and
various things like this
um oh i should say one very critical
fact about water
at zero degrees centigrade water freezes
turns into ice
ice for any given number of molecules
ice is bigger than liquid water
it's a weird thing water is unvery
unusual in that respect usually solids
of a particular substance are smaller
than the corresponding liquid usually
the atoms are the molecules are closer
packed in the solid than they are in the
liquid for water anomalously that is not
the case
however
as normally when you freeze water you
get this ice which is this crystal where
in the different forms of ice but
there's a particular form of ice that
you get when water freezes at normal
pressure
at zero degrees centigrade um and that
form of ice is bigger than liquid water
it will destroy cells it's bad news
okay if you can get down to minus 44
degrees centigrade uh water uh so-called
vitrifies
instead of turning into ice which is a
nice crystal where all the atoms are
lined up with all molecules are lined up
and it's a very regular array
water has another state which is glassy
it's amorphous the the kind of the
molecules are just all sort of pushed in
there and it's not um it's not with all
the molecules lined up and that state
is smaller than liquid water
and so if you could go
from
you know cool down cool down cool down
to
still liquid water
and then jump over the zero degrees
centigrade down to the minus 44 degrees
centigrade you would probably solve the
problem you would probably be able to
take
a
an organism
and uh
and freeze it um and uh
and get it to the point where it can um
uh where no cells are destroyed now
people have done a bunch of experiments
on a bunch of different kinds of tissues
trying to get it to the vitrification
point um without going through this sort
of intermediate zone
and there are a number of techniques
that involve i think um
let's say i think helium gas is a good
thing because it has very high thermal
how does that work
basically the problem is
if you can get cold
into every part of the organism quickly
enough you can probably get it to jump
over this intermediate zone of
temperatures and get down to the place
where verification will happen but it's
tough to get
the cold in quickly enough so to speak
now for example this is of interest in
sort of a in the practice of medicine
in things like organ transplants and
preserving organs and so on
and uh the the question is you know if
you take a kidney or a liver or
something like this or a heart and
you're trying to um uh
preserve it and you're trying to you
know be good if you could like freeze it
and just leave it in in
you know frozen for a month two months
whatever rather than having to
uh you know having to sort of transport
it very quickly and so there's there's
considerable interest even if you don't
think about kind of the take a whole
human and freeze them there's
considerable interest in this problem of
how do you take biological tissues and
get them to the point where they can be
really frozen without uh without being
destroyed and i think there's been slow
progress on on this topic i mean it's
been a sort of strange thing about
cryonics that while experiments have
been going on for 60 70 years or more um
it's uh and and there are companies that
will you know freeze people using the
best available technology
um
the it's um
uh
the amount that's been done on this is
really very modest compared to what you
might think given how important it would
be if it really worked because if you
imagine a situation i mean the the you
know the common scenario would be you
get some nasty disease nobody knows how
to cure that disease right now but one
can kind of tell that the research is
pointing in the direction where in 10 20
30 years that will disease will be
absolutely fine it'll be easy to cure
you know as has happened with many kinds
of cancers for example over the last few
decades
and other kinds of things um where we
say okay let's you know poor's life
uh get cryonically frozen and when one
knows how to fix whatever whatever was
wrong
then sort of uh deep
deep freeze
and get fixed and go on and uh you know
lead more life type thing
so and and obviously the biggest thing
that one doesn't know how to reverse yet
is aging
um the the question of why aging happens
at all is an interesting question
and the question of what's actually
going on what's going wrong you know is
it genetic damage is it oxide damage
from oxidation essentially metabolism
essentially the burning of material in
cells um is it uh
you know is it is it actually just
programmed cell death are we like
programmed because that's what's good
for the species to have us old folk um
eventually die off so the species can
kind of
have the new generation come in and and
uh take things over and so on is is it
something that is really just a a bug in
the system that was just the result of
evolution because a million years ago it
was really a good thing to let the new
god come in and get rid of the old god
maybe that isn't so true anymore i don't
know maybe it is still very true hard to
know but um uh in any case with
these different theories for what causes
aging and one doesn't really know uh and
one one wonders whether at some point in
the future they'll be kind of the the
elixir of eternal youth that people have
talked about for a long time where it's
just like uh there's some there's some
bug in our system that if we could only
fix it um we would be able to kind of
biologically regenerate forever because
our cells are most of our cells are
continually regenerating i mean it's not
the case if you say am i the same person
i was yesterday so to speak sort of an
interesting philosophical question you
know progressively the cells that are in
me my skin cells my blood cells my et
cetera et cetera et cetera cells um are
gradually turning over that you know
they'll after some days to months to
whatever
one generation of cells will die off
another set of cells will be produced
and gradually the me
is sort of turning over to a new set of
cells but i still think of it as me
one small exception is is most nerve
cells don't turn over like that most
nerve cells are like there for for a
lifetime so to speak there's a slow rate
of new nerve cell production and a rate
at which nerve cells die um but uh
sort of the i suppose the the the proto
theory which probably isn't really that
well supported by by data at this point
is sort of the more you use your brain
the more new no cells will be produced
um and uh the longer the whole thing
will will last so to speak at least
that's that's a theory that i i somehow
partly subscribe to
but in any case the um
the question of uh uh so you know one of
the key things with cryonics is you know
if in 50 years it's known kind of how to
reverse aging then if you can sort of
press the pause button and say okay my
you know my lifespan as it is right now
is up in x number of years but if you
can pause it for another 50 years or
something and then by the time your
pause is over um it's kind of like now
we know how to reverse aging and you can
keep going forever so to speak um that's
the um uh that's that's kind of the
the concept the hope
and
you know one can certainly debate the
question of what would the world be like
if people were
uh immortal
and um i i have to say that sometimes i
think as i look at kind of the way in
which new ideas come in in the world and
things i've done to try and sort of
induce new things to happen i sometimes
think that if it was biological
evolution that made finite lifetimes it
wasn't so
it wasn't such a dumb thing for it to do
because the it is the case that uh the
kind of you know people get set in a
particular direction and if you say well
there's this new stuff it's really good
they'll be like well i've been happily
doing this for the last 40 years and i
just want to keep on doing what i've
been doing and if it was like well i
just want to keep on doing what i've
been doing for 400 years or 4 000 years
uh things could get very
things could could really slow down in
terms of of any kind of change something
that that's good something that's bad um
i think it's a mixed bag myself
i think that there's sometimes people
say the new is really good there's
everything should be new and they say
but it turns out that we've accumulated
a lot of things in our in the history of
our civilization that i think are pretty
interesting and not so bad and to just
say the new is the only thing we want to
consider is is also a mistake on the
other hand to say only the old is worth
considering and there could never be
anything new created that's also a
mistake i mean one of the things that
has come out of a lot of science i've
done is the realization that for very
theoretical reasons about the science
there will always be a frontier of new
things to discover one will never be
finished there will be given the
physical universes that exist there will
always be new technology to be invented
there will always be new things to be
discovered
that's just a sort of mathematical fact
and so it isn't
that that's something where you can
expect that sort of change will
continually be able to happen whether
you choose to make change happen well
that depends on sort of what part of the
space of possible things one might
invent do we want to live in and that's
a societal choice and so on which is a
more complicated thing to talk about
but any case back to cryonics
so sort of the idea
of cryonics is the sort of the the
freeze and pause type thing now it's a
complicated thing because if you imagine
and i was uh sort of interesting thought
experiment
if you say
imagine you were frozen 100 years ago
and you wake up today
how do you sort of how do you view
society today how do you view you know
is it the case that
that you kind of have a good time with
that sort of time shift or is that time
shift actually like a well i was doing
really well in my particular place and
time but if you shift me to another time
or even another place
it might be a quite different story so
those are sort of uh some of the
questions about cryonics and i've
noticed that people have a
a some people are like cryonics that's
the thing you know i think it's really
great and some people are like i'm gonna
live my life at this time in history and
that's it
um and uh i think it's it's an
interesting thing to kind of realize
what it feels like to kind of wake up at
another time and so on and i i think
i've i've had this experience a little
bit in a strange way because
particularly for example i i did a bunch
of work in physics when i was much
younger and then i kind of in effect in
effect
was sort of cryonically froze myself
with respect to physics for about 40
years and then sort of came back again
and that's been an interesting thing
because it's like careers you know the
people i knew they were starting their
careers 40 years ago
now it's 40 years later they may be
ending their careers it's kind of like a
a time shift and it's sort of an
interesting thing it's it's it's a
little bit disorienting in some ways but
it's fascinating in other ways because
you get to say hey i wonder what
happened to that thing well now you can
tell
i'm i'm sort of having the same
experience actually with the kind of
ideas around complexity which i'm just
sort of returning to and thinking about
how to take the next steps with and
that's again something that i really
pursued up to about 35 years ago and
then kind of
have not been as connected to for a very
long time i also personally noticed this
a bit uh you know i grew up in in
england and uh i've lived in the us now
for what is it 44 years
um and uh
the you know when i go back to england
it's kind of like i'm it's funny because
you know i remember things as they were
44 years ago and it's like i'm i'm sort
of asking for for types of candy where
the person at the store is
is looking at me like what on earth are
you talking about and it's like well
that was a thing back back in the day
but oh whoops it's been overtaken by
american candy or something since then
and and probably uh longer ago than the
person at the store was born and things
and it's all very very confusing and
it's kind of a realization that there's
a certain one is used to a certain time
and place so to speak and there's a
definite adjustment to making going to a
different one so i think that's that's
kind of the more sort of personal
societal aspects of cryonics i think
there are other aspects of cryonics that
are kind of um interesting um i mean i
think that the primary issue is the sort
of technical one
of sort of how do you freeze quickly
enough and how do you sort of get how do
you how do you get freezing stuff
into something like a human quickly
enough it turns out people do
experiments on rats and mice and things
a lot easier with rats and mice because
they're smaller and the time it takes
for sort of the cold to get into the
brain of a you know every part of the
brain of a mouse is much smaller than
the time for a human so you have to kind
of invent these methods of well
typically using the
circulatory system the bloodstream to
just get stuff in get the cold stuff in
as quickly as possible and you know
there's a convenient fact that because
the the circulatory system is for
delivering oxygen to our tissues the
every you know the capillaries uh grow
out in our circular system to the point
where there is a capillary within maybe
two microns of every single piece of
tissue in your body because otherwise
that piece of tissue wouldn't stay alive
because what happens is there are red
blood cells delivering oxygen and those
red blood cells are kind of dumping off
their oxygen it's diffusing through that
last two microns to get to the
particular cell that it's supposed to be
delivering oxygen to that allows the
cell to metabolize and generate energy
and do all those good things so that's
kind of a system that we have a built-in
system for delivering stuff to different
parts of our bodies but that stuff is
usually blood which is at whatever 98.6
degrees fahrenheit or whatever it is um
and uh is that core temperature is that
just the temperature one measure i think
it's core temperature so that yes about
that temperature
uh
36 degrees celsius i think um that right
shows what shows what countries i've
lived in what whether i know the body
temperature in celsius or not um
in any case the the uh and so you know
the challenge is could you really have
that be minus 44 degrees centigrade and
how quickly can you do that and that's
kind of the the very practical almost
physics-like challenge of cryonics
and uh
i think there are other aspects of
cryonics like
if you say
uh you know in the legal system if
you're a
a um
you know a living
sort of active person you can do things
like own things
if you are chronically frozen what does
that mean
you know are you do you count as oh no
that person is dead you know you have to
um uh you know it's all the estate taxes
and and uh all this all this kind of
thing or not there's a bunch of issues
around that um there's also well there's
a lot of lot of a lot of questions
around those kinds of things society
hasn't been set up for cryonics yet
um and uh there's a of course cryonics
has to work better and more convincingly
because right now the technologies that
exist will destroy cells they may not
destroy them too badly but they will
destroy cells and the only way to to
bring those cells back would be some
kind of nanotechnology
some kind of molecular scale repair of
cells which there's no reason to think
won't be possible at some point in the
future but it's it's more work so to
speak and it's not just you know press
the reanimate button and um and and walk
out of the uh
you know walk out of the facility type
thing
so anyway that that's a um
uh
some thoughts about cryonics i i should
say that the other the other sort of
competing concept of cryonics
is you know forget trying to freeze and
reanimate
just freeze
and just say
you can and just make it so that every
molecule in your body is kind of frozen
in place
and there are uh there are things you
know when when you take
a random
specimen some biological specimen
and it's a poor dead
frog or something i'm really squeamish
about dead things so i i hate even this
concept but um uh you know take the dead
frog and put it in
in uh formaldehyde or whatever and and
then it'll just stay there
for forever and like the specimens that
charles darwin collected
in the um you know 1830s or something
are still sitting in the in the british
natural history museum um in these jars
of of of formaldehyde or whatever
formula and i guess um and uh uh and the
way that happens is that that substance
is this pretty small molecule that kind
of gets into all these different parts
of the of the organism all the different
tissues and it just locks all the
proteins in place
so all these all these proteins that
will be flapping around and having
chemical reactions and so on it's just
lock them
and um so that can preserve presumably
the the structure of different kinds of
of things so a question would be if you
take a brain
uh with its with all of its nerve cells
and all of those detailed connections
between nerve cells that store memories
and you essentially you freeze it not by
changing its temperature but you freeze
it by putting in some substance that
basically locks all the molecules in
place what can you do with that and
could you at some point in the future
just say okay we're going to do a scan
of that and forget how the brain
originally worked we're just going to
scan it and we're going to put it in
some digital form and then it'll be like
every memory that was stored there is is
still preserved so that's kind of a plan
a second plan for how you preserve these
things now that's a very complicated
philosophical question it's like it's
you it's your memories it's everything
about you but it got frozen in this way
where it isn't the the physical material
of you and then it gets kind of
reconstituted in digital form and then
there's a question is that you is that
not you how do you how does that feel
you know this relates very much to sort
of the inner questions of consciousness
and so on of you know you is there some
feeling of consciousness that would be
broken by this transition from the
physical you
to this sort of digital copy of the
memories of you and i think these are
all interesting questions and they're
all interesting sort of philosophical
questions it's worth realizing that a
lot of sort of the what is us is a story
of what we remember from the past and so
the digital copy of us
with the same memories
is still going to feel like it's us so
to speak
in that digital copy because it has
those same memories now if you say as i
think about a moment in the future
when everything's going to get frozen
and it's going to a thousand years are
going to pass
and then it's going to sort of reappear
in some digital form how does that feel
to me now well the answer doesn't feel
like anything because as soon as you
stop the thought process for you
there is nothing to feel so to speak
so it's kind of like in um
when you think about physics and you
think about time passing and i was
talking earlier about time passing for
photons and things for a photon no time
passes
in in the universe at large in the
middle of a black hole for example time
simply stops
the the in our models of physics there's
a sort of this continual updating of the
universe the continual updating of this
network that represents space and
everything in space in the universe and
it can be the case in the center of
black hole at a space-time singularity
that time simply stops
nothing gets updated anymore so if
you're saying what does it feel like
for you to be at a place where time
stops so it doesn't feel like anything
because there's no feeling going on
time has simply stopped
and that's i think what you know if you
imagine kind of the the feeling of it's
it's kind of like the it's a it's a it's
it's qualitatively like to go to sleep
and wake up again but it isn't really
like that because actually really
nothing was happening it was it was just
time was stopped like for a photon like
in a space-time singularity um and uh
you know the at a space-time singularity
well
they're all questions about whether
whether it can restart again
and um that that's something that uh
what we're just talking about in the
context of chaotics
um
let's see
uh
the questions here
about um
there's a question from philip
why does time seem to speed up as we age
you know i've wondered about that i kind
of have this impression that it's all
fractional
that
you know we remember a certain amount of
stuff
and the what happened in the past year
is to be compared with everything we
remember so if we've been around for 40
years 60 years
20 years whatever
each successive year is to be compared
to the memories we've had of all
previous years so it's it's kind of just
a ratio and that means that as one gets
older any given actual year that passes
is a smaller fraction of one's life and
so it is it feels like it's it's less
time so to speak because it's just a
smaller fraction that's that's my that's
my best guess about that phenomenon and
i think that um uh it is an interesting
question if sort of there was effective
immortality and people were routinely
living for you know ten thousand years
or something like this um would it would
it feel like would it would it really
not be relevant because it's all kind of
um
uh it's all kind of logarithmic i
suppose so let's see so that's an
interesting question
in if it really was fractional like that
i would assume
that
the the integral still diverges so you
would still feel like you were living
for infinite time it wouldn't be the
case as happens in some situations in
general relativity the theory of gravity
where where time
sort of slows down to the point where
the the total amount of time like for
example when you fall into a black hole
at least in a non-rotating black hole
the time before you reach the space-time
singularity is finite and that means
that that even though so time
uh it doesn't quite work this way in
that case but i think there may be cases
where this works that way where time is
sort of speeding up for you and there
there's a point at which yes in fact
that does happen you reach um
uh slightly more complicated scenario
let me not describe it in detail here
but but um basically it's as if
um
time is speeding up
but you reach that's right you reach so
that this happens
yes it happens for an observer
from who's falling into the black hole
and observing the outside the rest of
the universe the the as the observer
falls into the black hole
time
to somebody for outside the black hole
that that thing falling into the black
hole
time seems to be running slower and
slower for it so if there was a clock
falling into a black hole when it's far
away from the black hole the clock's
ticking once a second let's say looked
at from outside the black hole as it
falls in the clock will just look like
it's ticking slower and slower and
slower and as it reaches the event
horizon of the black hole it will just
seem like it froze
okay now as far as the clock is
concerned the clock is looking outside
at the rest of the universe and the
clock its experience of the world is
based on its its
ticks of the clock so every second it
experiences a second of time but because
to the outside it looks like it froze
what that means to the clock is the
clock at that moment
will
the clock will just think i'm just
ticking tick tick tick i'm a happily
ticking clock
and when i look at the outside universe
the whole future of the universe will
flash by
and so what happens is as the clock is
moving as the clock is experiencing
every tick of the clock
it's effectively seeing the whole future
history of the universe at an
increasingly rapid rate sort of zoomed
by so in a sense that's the experience
that that's an analogy for the
experience of uh us humans would be kind
of what happens in in the um in the
ticking clock in the black hole event
horizon what happens in that case is
different from what i suspect happens
experientially for humans which is in
finite time
the the in a
uh yes in a finite time for the clock it
sees the whole future of the universe so
time effectively speeds up for that
clock where from the outside world there
is a moment at which the clock freezes
it doesn't have its next tick but before
it had that next tick from the point of
view of the clock it sees the whole
future of the universe zoom by
and so that um and that's a case where
unlike what i think happens
experientially for humans it's a case
where kind of your experience of the
world will take in finite time you will
experience the whole future of the world
so to speak so what seems to you like
only a finite time is the infinite
future of the world
and again for humans my my guess is if
it really is a fractional type of thing
the way the math would work out would
mean that you would still experience an
infinite time if you if you lived
forever it would still seem like you
were living forever it wouldn't seem
like oh the whole future of the universe
is just happening in uh in finite time
let's see
uh
well
um
there's a question here very rather
different kind
uh from tech
uh how can we learn physics or math at a
young age
organizing one's life order of topics
experience uh
what what's what is it what is it to be
a young physics enthusiast and so on
look the the the thing i think i've
talked about this a few times before
but
i think it it's somewhat personality
dependent some people can just read a
textbook
and
get
a good understanding of the subject from
reading the textbook
some people you read the textbook and
you do the exercise you get a good
understanding
some people it's only in that lecture
class with an actual person talking
about things that you can get that
understanding some people can get the
corresponding thing from videos and so
on
some people like me don't do very well
just reading a book
and even maybe doing the exercises in
the book although i have to say i'm not
very patient about doing exercises i was
just confronted with a book where half
its content seems to be in exercises and
so you really can't even read the
content of the book without reading the
exercises and i was realizing the
authors quite cleverly had set it up so
you really can't understand this book
without actually thinking through the
exercises so i'm afraid i may be picking
another book for that subject um it's a
book about higher category theory um
the so anyway the the i think
for somebody like me
i find the best way to learn subjects is
to have a problem a question that i'm
trying to answer and then given that
question i kind of you know i have a
definite direction and i'm pulling in
things that i need to know from this
place in that place and the other and
that's how i kind of
that's how i kind of learn the subject
and to have something that i'm creating
that uh
you know at least i believe to be new um
and i believe to be something that i'm
sort of making a contribution in
that that is a way to learn things like
for example i have been learning uh i
think i've talked about some of the
things i've been learning recently but
i've been learning a whole bunch of
subjects recently because essentially
the a bunch of things that have come out
of our physics project have given us i
think a new paradigm for modeling a new
method for modeling all kinds of things
in the world i call it the
multi-computational paradigm and it
really has to do with
the idea well the thing that's happened
last probably 30 years or so is this
idea of using programs and computation
as a way to model things in the world
but usually what happens there is you
say i've got this program i've got
something that describes the state of
this thing in the world and then this
program tells me what the state of the
thing in the world that the next step is
going to be and the next step and the
next step it's kind of the single thread
of time where at every moment you're
kind of applying this computational rule
to get to the next step but what happens
in our physics project is it's much more
bizarre than that there are many threads
of time that are branching and merging
and there isn't just one thread of time
there are there are many separate
threads of time and that the way that we
experience that
is through as observers we are kind of
uh conflating together if that what
happens on different threads of time the
thing that sort of tipped me off on this
is what happens in quantum mechanics
where what we think is going on in
quantum mechanics
is that there are these different
threads of time but as observers we our
brains are also following these
different threads of time and so there's
this weird process of how our sort of
branching brains perceive this branching
universe and the way that we conflate
different threads of time and in fact
the phenomenon of quantum entanglement i
realized just this past week is very
beautifully understandable and
explainable by just saying it really is
just these different threads of time
that we are conflating together and that
really is the process of entanglement is
that conflation being done by by us
humans because our brains are also
insofar as we believe that we experience
a definite thread of time that we have a
definite sort of consciousness that's
moving through time we are necessarily
taking those things which really in some
outside sense are different threads of
time and when we're knitting them
together um and so
in any case that's sort of a core of
this multi-computational paradigm and
what i've realized is that it provides
one a sort of new raw material for
models in all kinds of different areas
so i think in in chemistry molecular
biology
um in
economics and linguistics
in evolutionary biology
in immunology a bunch of different areas
this this is a potential sort of new
kind of raw material for models of
things and what's really amazing about
it is that
that in in its way of providing new
models for things it is really following
the pattern that we now understand
physics follows and that means that that
that pattern actually means that there
are then physics-like laws that apply to
these other other kinds of systems and
essentially what happens is i think i
don't yet know for sure but i think that
the way that we perceive the physical
universe the physical universe
ultimately is all these atoms of space
and they have all these different
connections they have all these
different possible paths for different
kinds of connections that can develop
all these very complicated things are
happening but we humans with our sort of
conscious experience of the world are
essentially parsing we're sampling
what's going on in a particular way that
sort of builds the reality that we
experience
and so uh what i think is the case is
that we are a certain kind of observer
of the physical universe
when it's a question of what's happening
i don't know to molecules and some kind
of chemical reaction process
what kind of observers
of chemistry should we think we are so
for example one of the things we might
say you've got all these molecules
they're all you know for example in us
in in molecular biology and and so on
there are all these different molecules
in a cell and they're all interacting
with each other and proteins are
interacting and other molecules are
interacting and there's this big
complicated network of interactions
that's happening on
and that network of interactions is
happening right down at the level of
this molecule interacted with this other
one then it went off and then it
interacted with another molecule then it
came back and interacted with the first
molecule again there's a big complicated
network of interactions that's going on
and so then the question is when we
uh the question is what matters about
that network of reactions and what do we
perceive about it so the thing that's
most common in chemistry is to say well
we're just going to perceive the total
concentration of every molecule we're
just going to say there's this amount of
this molecule this amount of this
molecule will have these rate equations
in chemistry that tell us how you know
when there's enough of this molecule on
that molecule they'll have reactions and
they'll produce these other molecules
and we can write down these differential
equations and there's a whole sort of
collection of differential equations a
whole network of differential equations
we can solve them we can find how the
concentration of these chemicals changes
with time okay that's been so the
traditional view in chemistry and in in
biochemistry of thinking about how these
kinds of things work
so i suspect that there's sort of a
different level that this
multi-computational idea suggests which
is actually look at the individual
molecules and say there are other things
you know looking at every individual
molecule it's just too much detail
you'll never know what's going on the
question is is the sampling of what's
happening really at the level of
chemical concentrations where every copy
of that molecule you just conflate it
together you just count how many of them
there are or is there more detail that
matters does it matter that this
molecule was going off in this direction
with this orientation and it could then
interact with this other one later in in
the same in such and such an orientation
and so on you might say well why does it
matter because we're not able to sense
what happens in a biochemical system at
the level of which direction is each
molecule going in and so on well we're
not with our current chemistry it's not
obvious that biology is not able to do
that
you know when we look at membranes in in
cells and things like this uh in
organelles and cells and so on and all
kinds of all kinds of different detailed
features it's not obvious that those
things aren't acting as essentially
chemical observers that are observing
different kinds of things than your
average chemist who is studying things
with sort of a large scale that a
macroscopic scale is studying so that's
an example of of of how that might work
and you know the thing that has been my
sort of uh
inspirational
kind of
concept model for this is something
about the history of biology which is
what happened in 1953
when
before that time genetics was this area
where people knew a certain amount about
genes and how you know recessive and
dominant genes and there were all these
different rules for how genes combined
nobody really knew what a gene was it
was just some trait of an organism that
was somehow passed to its to its progeny
and so on
um and so that was um so so it was a lot
of complicated detailed facts about how
that worked
the um the thing that happened in 1953
was the realization that individual
molecules in particular dna could store
information that you that it people who
thought molecules just molecules you
count how many of the molecule there is
and that's all you get to say about the
molecule people didn't think that on an
individual molecule there would be
information stored but that was the big
thing that led to modern molecular
biology and the whole sort of genomics
uh world et cetera et cetera et cetera i
kind of have this suspicion that when we
think about molecular biology uh in the
future that the thing that might have
been missed is something about the fact
that that actually isn't
um
the uh
there's actually more stuff going on
than you're capturing by just saying all
i care about is the concentration of
chemicals that there's there's stuff at
the level of these these much more
detailed um uh kinds of kinds of
processes which will be captured by this
kind of multi-computational paradigm um
and are not really captured by just
thinking about oh we've got these
chemical reactions that was a long kind
of side comment to saying that i've been
trying to learn things about these
different areas including chemistry um
but another one i've been trying to
learn about is immunology
um where
the um the the principal question there
is sort of how does the immune system
work
you know we have with the different
parts there's the innate immune system
the adaptive immune system the innate
immune system we share with lots of
lower organisms and it's kind of
basically molecule comes in
and then there are various heuristics to
say that's a bad that's a bad antigen
that's something that's a bad molecule
we don't like that molecule and there's
some sort of fixed patterns that the
innate immune system matches against
molecules that are coming in to say
that's something bad let's try and push
it out
but
that that that's a fixed set so
obviously there are viruses and bacteria
and other things which have learned to
evade the immediate mate innate immune
system because it's like if you're a
virus and you're evolving quickly on a
time scale of water months
then you quickly can you can have sort
of new viruses that change and they can
readily sort of avoid the issue that
what the innate immune system delivers
so then there's the adaptive immune
system and the adaptive immune system is
picking is is uh there are maybe 10
billion maybe a trillion depends on the
piece of the adapter immune system
different kinds of antibodies or t cells
t cell receptors that are the things
that are sort of matching the antigens
that are coming in matching the bad
stuff that's coming in and marking it
and saying okay go other parts of the
immune system and destroy this
particular cell or this particular
this particular bacterium or whatever
else
and the the question of how the adaptive
immune system works
is one that was sort of figured out in
the 1940s 50s 60s
and sort of the key idea is that all the
time we're randomly producing all these
different kinds of antibodies but as
soon as those antibodies have something
to bind to as soon as there's an antigen
to which those antibodies sort of match
then those antibodies there's a sort of
positive feedback loop that generates
more and more of those antibodies and so
that's how we mount an immune response
to a particular antigen is by having
that antigen
we have this sort of random collection
out of these 10 billion at possible
antibodies they're lots randomly being
produced all the time and you know some
number of them will match a particular
antigen well enough that they will be
amplified and we'll get many more of
those antibodies and so then those
antibodies will be more effective at
marking new antigen that comes in of
that type and having the immune system
destroy the the cells that have been
infected with that antigen or whatever
else goes on
so the question really is in that setup
where you've got this kind of space of
all possible uh kind of
all cut possible kinds of immune
cells all possible antibodies they're
really two parts the b cells that
produce antibodies and the t cells that
have this t cell receptor and the t
cells directly bind to other cells to to
to attack them whereas the the b cells
there's an antibody it marks the
antibody marks things and then other
cells come in and deal with that so it's
a slightly more indirect mechanism and
in fact antibody response is the more
common thing that's been studied a lot
in immunology t cell response which
turns out to be important for
coronaviruses like covet 19
that um the t-cell response is less well
studied and it's more difficult to uh if
you just take a blood sample it's much
easier to these antibodies just pretty
small molecules and it's pretty easy to
assay to figure out how much of that
antibody of a particular kind there is
it's more difficult to do the same thing
for t cell receptors although it's
become possible now
um but anyway so so there's these two
slightly different mechanisms but either
way what's happening is
you know antigen comes in antibodies
there's this random collection of
different antibodies being produced
when an antibody is a hit
it actually matches the antigen the
antibody the production of that antibody
is is expanded it starts being there's a
positive feedback loop starts being
produced more and more and more and then
it's able to mount an immune response
more easily same thing happens with
vaccines where they are kind of uh
pretending to be antigen and causing
these antibodies to be produced they're
actually therapies even for for cov19
there are direct therapies that sort of
put in antibodies that kind of take get
rid of the step
of um the so-called
monoclonal antibodies which are produced
as a slightly weird process which is
using a form of
form of blood cancer that is something
which generates cells very rapidly is
sort of piggybacked on um nobody has the
the no no blood cancer and an actual
human is involved but it's a it's a
thing where the kind of the biology of
that is used to be able to just generate
lot more and more and more of these um
these cells that produce these
antibodies but that's so you can sort of
directly inject antibodies that's a
therapy for percovery 19 that seems
rather good actually um the uh but in
any case the the thing that um um
is the more common case is
is antigen comes in your random
selection of antibodies that are always
existing sort of randomly in the sort of
field of different antibodies
some of those will be the the winners
and then they'll get amplified okay so
what happens then so one of the issues
is how do they stop being amplified well
so a theory that was developed in the
60s kind of network theory of the immune
system says well in addition to the
antibodies there are eventually
anti-antibodies that knock down
the production of antibodies and by
and and cause you to stop you know that
they sort of attack the antibodies that
have been produced and then there might
be
anti-anti-antibodies and overall there's
a whole network of different different
kinds of um
antibodies same with t cells t cells one
actually has actually videos of t cells
uh binding together actually interacting
with each other going away they actually
have direct interactions with each other
that sort of build up a network of kinds
of characteristics of t cells and so on
so the question is uh in that setup how
does the immune system and how does
immune memory work because one of the
things that's confusing is you know you
get a vaccine you have a disease it's
like for life you can potentially be uh
immune or more immune to that particular
disease how does how does the memory of
the immune system work and people have
kind of imagined that there must be some
kind of cell one of the types of b cells
for example that produces antibodies
that must be somewhere sort of hiding in
the bone marrow uh ready to pounce at a
moment's notice
and sitting there just hanging out for
for your whole life
waiting to pounce
that seems implausible because most b
cells don't live very long there are
some mechanisms that make b cells live
longer when they're being useful but
living decades as opposed to a few
months
seems a bit implausible and so it seems
more likely that what's happening is
that sort of one population of b cells
is somehow passing its knowledge to
another generation um it's kind of like
the way that genomics works in organisms
might be like the way the brain works i
mean the question of whether we directly
remember things that happened to us x
number of decades ago
is not clear it's not clear we directly
remember
as opposed to we remember memories of
remembering
and it's more likely i suspect that we
remember memories of remembering
and and uh that the same kind of thing
is happening in the immune system that
it's sort of remembering that it
remembered something and and that that
is it needs this whole dynamic network
of interactions to kind of
maintain its memory so the question is
how does that all work and i was
realizing that this multi-computation
paradigm that i've been developing
actually might give one a really good
way to make models of the immune system
that's of high interest because they're
questions like you have a vaccine that
produces
that causes you to produce antibodies of
a very specific type um and then the
question is when the virus mutates that
it's kind of like you're moving around
in shape space and does the production
of antibodies here how much does it help
you as it moves around in shape space
how much does the fact that you have
different kinds of sort of
processes going on how does that affect
things how does if there is a sort of
antibody anti-antibody kind of cycle how
long does that take how long does that
how does that relate to things like
seasonal variation
of uh in epidemiology things of this
kind which which uh there's a lot that
is not known and so i i lost kind of
paid attention to immunology maybe
30 something years ago and so i knew a
little bit about how things worked at
that time and so i've now been sort of
trying to learn it again and the main
thing is that um
there's kind of these um
uh you know big thick books about this
that have just tons of facts
about immunology and all these different
kinds of t cells and you know back when
i learned biology as a kid it was just
like the blood has white blood cells red
blood cells and white blood cells but no
white blood cells is not it it's
t cells and b cells and then helper t
cells and th1 cells and cd8 positive
cells and et cetera et cetera et cetera
it becomes a much more complicated story
and and so that's a question but my
effort to learn it if i just read these
immunology books without having some
kind of model in mind without having
some objective in mind for me at least i
wouldn't remember them at all um but uh
when um uh you know having some definite
objective and some definite sort of
scaffolding that i'm trying to fit that
knowledge that i'm trying to get into
then i have a real chance to remember it
right i think we have to wrap up really
soon here
um
and uh
let's see
um
[Music]
oh there are lots of
fun
things
um
fun questions here all right but i think
we probably
uh maybe i can do one more
okay
uh there's a question here
if the center of the earth is really hot
like the sun
how come it isn't melting everything
between us and it
okay
the basic reason for that is that in a
sense the speed of heat
is very slow
what do i mean by the speed of heat
well if you you know
it's some uh
the um
when the question is if you have a a
i don't know a metal rod no let's say if
you have
yeah take a metal rod you heat one end
of the metal rod how quickly does the
heat from that one end of the metal rod
get to the other end of the metal rod
well for a metal rod it's quite fast
what's actually happening when the heat
is is going from one end to the other
what is heat heat is motion of molecules
so when you heat something up it means
the molecules are running around faster
and faster and what's happening is the
molecules at one end that are being
heated up they're running around really
fast they're hitting molecules that are
kind of still running slowly and they're
making those molecules go faster just
because when they collide it's like
billiard balls colliding they the
billable that's going fast hits the one
that's going that's just sitting there
not not moving at all and it makes that
other billiard ball go faster too
and so that's what's happening that the
end of the rod that's being heated is um
is causing molecules the molecules are
all running around faster and faster
because being heated at that end then
those ones are transmitting the heat
effectively to the the rest of the rod
and the rate at which that heat is
transmitted is determined by a thing
called the thermal conductivity
coefficient
um and that
that that's a number that basically is
telling you um
that for every material there is a
definite thermal conductivity
just like there's a definite density how
much does the thing weigh per unit
volume there's a definite thermal
conductivity which tells you how fast is
heat transmitted through the material
and for metals it's quite fast and the
main reason for that is because actually
in metals heat is transmitted through
electrons and electrons in a metal the
definition of a metal is that electrons
kind of
flow freely throughout the metal that's
why you can have an electric current uh
sort of easily going through a material
in in other materials in non-metals uh
that don't conduct electricity they also
don't well they often don't conduct heat
as well there are some exceptions like
diamond for example there's a really
good conductor of heat even though it is
not a conductor of electricity um but
the um the basic point is when
when in something like a crystal heat is
represented by sort of things wiggling
around molecules wiggling around they're
things called phonons which are
essentially the the particles of heat in
a crystal phonons are well it's kind of
like a sound and sound
in uh in the air for example that's
compression that's some sort of uh
higher pressure lower pressure regions
phonons are kind of the really
microscopic version of that that are
atoms moving closer together and further
apart within a crystal lattice and so
you can ask sort of how fast do these
things move how fast does heat move
actually a chap called joseph fourier
back in the 1800s uh figured out um a
bunch of stuff about kind of the the
heat equation and this question
of sort of how fast does heat move
unlike something like a a wave on a
string or on the ocean which can like
just the wave is just propagating
without changing when heat propagates it
gradually gets more smeared out it
doesn't it isn't the case that a sort of
heat pulse just goes as a heat pulse
that just goes down the rod um you know
as a heat pulse as it would for sound
for example for compression you would
get this pulse that goes down the rod in
the case of heat the pulse kind of
smears out it gets broader and broader
but it's still it's it's it can it moves
at a certain rate and that rate at which
it moves determined by the stomach
conductivity the thermal conductivity is
basically determined by how fast
the
different
for example in a metal as i said the the
electrons
which are nice light particles are going
quickly and they are um and kind of the
heat at one end is quickly transmitted
to the other end because it's being
transmitted by electrons they have it
has high thermal conductivity in other
materials the heat is transmitted by
sort of a piece of crystal wiggles
around and then it wiggles some other
part of the crystal and the rate at
which that happens is determined by
characteristics of the crystal lattice
and other things and that determines the
rate at which heat can move through a
material okay having said all that the
question is if you have something let's
say
you have the sun is is uh it's really
hot one day
and the sun is and then you but you say
if i dig a hole in the ground
how long is it does it notice if you're
an earthworm and you live an inch below
the surface of the the of the ground
um do you notice that was really hot
today
okay you can ask that question for an
earthworm an inch below the surface of
the soil you can ask that question for
an earthworm a foot below the surface of
the soil or a hundred feet below
and turns out that the sort of speed of
heat being transmitted through soil or
rock is really slow and so for example i
don't know how how deep you have to go
maybe a couple of feet down
the the temperature of the soil
throughout the year even though it might
be a really baking day at one point and
really cold in the winter the the
temperature is just stays i think in
many places like 50 degrees fahrenheit
just stays a constant temperature you
don't have to dig very deep before the
speed of heat has been sort of too slow
to reach that at any time during the
year so even though it's really hot it's
sometimes really cold at other times
it's just like the soil is at a constant
temperature
so if you go if you think about the
center of the earth
the center of the earth is hot
uh quite hot
um but
the speed at which that heat has been
able to diffuse out to the outer parts
of the earth is really slow
and
in fact it's so slow that some of the
heat of the earth probably maybe half
the heat of the earth
was heat that came when the earth was
formed
you know
four billion years ago 4.6 billion years
ago when the earth was formed there was
lots of heat and it was trapped inside
the earth and all the rock all the solid
rock that kind of uh condensed out of
out of the liquid that well the liquid
core of the earth
all of that
is just the heat from the inside of the
earth is not reaching the outside just
hasn't taken hasn't been long enough to
reach the outside i don't know how long
it would take but i'm guessing it's in
the trillions of years or more to to to
reach which is which we don't have in
the in so far in the universe
for that heat to kind of reach out to
the outside so to speak so we've sort of
trapped heat inside the earth it might
be said that there is a different
mechanism for heat being in the earth
which is not just relic heat from when
the earth was formed but also heat from
the decay of radioactive elements that
contributes part of the heat of the
earth as well but uh so that's that's
that's the reason is that just hasn't
been time eventually um
eventually the sort of the temperature
of the earth will presumably come to
equilibrium it'll presumably be of
constant temperatures throughout the
earth so for example the moon
okay so the earth has a liquid core it
actually has a solid core right at the
center of that of that liquid core but
most of the down uh
what is it
50 miles down something like that you
get to the mantle of the earth
um and um you and then it's liquid all
the way to the to the very center um and
uh you know the earth hasn't had time
to cool uniformly the moon is smaller
and has had time presumably and it does
not have a liquid core
mars i think is thought to maybe have a
tiny liquid core
um and so so this thing the answer is
that eventually
eventually things will be
uh will come to
there's a certain amount of heat in the
earth
and eventually everything will come to a
constant temperature and actually it's a
good question what that constant
temperature would be i actually don't
know the answer to that um well i think
it might be determined by
hmm it's complicated because it will
depend on
uh the atmosphere which also
is a barrier because the the temperature
of space
is much lower the temperature of space
is kind of hard to assess at temperature
in space because temperature is
associated with the motion of lots of
molecules and in space there aren't any
molecules like in interstellar space
there's one molecule one atom per cubic
meter roughly so it's very low density
of material and and you can say well
what's the temperature of that well you
can say how fast is that atom running
around but it's a slightly weird notion
of temperature um and i think uh
but but you know the the temperature of
the radiation of the photons in space is
about 2.7 kelvins 2.7 degrees above
absolute zero that's about minus 270
degrees centigrade um is the temperature
which is essentially the relic heat from
the big bang at the beginning of the
universe
is left over at the level of about three
degrees above absolute zero of of
radiation temperature and uh because
of the way that things that those
photons at that temperature whenever
they hit atoms they also make the atoms
be at that temperature so in a sort of
first approximation the temperature of
space is three kelvins three degrees
above absolute zero but there's the you
know for the earth to come to that
temperature is something that it has a
lot of kind of stuff like the atmosphere
where um it's kind of uh
where where heat doesn't propagate very
quickly heat doesn't doesn't travel
through that quickly so it's kind of
shielded from being taken down to that
temperature but if you kind of waited
long enough eventually it would end up
at the temperature of essentially the
temperature of the whole universe the
temperature of space
which is effectively three degrees above
absolute zero
all right um i think we should wrap up
for now and um
uh thanks for joining us actually i have
another live stream that's part of my
day job talking about design of
software
systems and i think we're talking about
um we're reviewing some visualization
capabilities for the next version of
wolfram language and that is coming up
in about 10 minutes
but thanks for joining us here i see
there are questions that i didn't get to
today which i look forward to getting to
next week and please think of other
questions you might like to ask
and feel free to um
to to ask them next week and uh i look
forward to trying to answer them great